Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass in den internationalen Ligen der Männer ist viel los. Das wollen wir hier besprechen im Lieblingsformat. Lieber Hörer, viele Hörerinnen und Hörer der Ligatour hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Das ist doch schön, wenn die Versprecher schon im Intro losgehen. Aber hier wird natürlich nichts gefaked, nichts geschnitten. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei der dieswöchigen Ligatour. Wir wollen blicken auf die Premier League, die Serie A, die Ligue 1 und la Liga. Wie immer begrüße ich deshalb vier Gäste bei mir. Zum einen Fabian Pakulat. Hallo Fabian, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Und dann Alexis Menuge natürlich für die Ligue 1. Hallo Alexis. Mario Rieker für die Serie A ist mit dabei. Hallo Mario. Und wir beginnen dann gleich mit Uli Hebel, der noch wichtige Verpflichtungen hat. Das kann nur ein Intensivgespräch mit irgendeinem Scout von, ja, weiß nicht, Preston North haben wir, glaube ich, im Vorgespräch gesagt, als du noch nicht dabei warst, Uli Hebel sein. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du hier bist. Genau, das war ja völlig klar. Wir beginnen deshalb mit der Premier League, weil wir dich nämlich auch schon früher verabschieden werden. Da hast du, wie alle anderen ja auch, zwei Themen mitgebracht. Und du möchtest unter anderem über die Spurs sprechen und einen Trainer, der – kann es sein, dass der mal wieder eine rote Karte gesehen hat? Also, wenn ich von Antonio konnte etwas mitbekommen, dann sind es immer sehr aufgeregte Memes um ihn oder in denen er sehr aufgeregt ist. Ich vermute, die Aufregung, die jetzt auch rechtfertigt, dass wir hier über ihn sprechen, kommt unter anderem durch das Ausscheiden gegen Milan. Man hat im Hinspiel 0 zu 1 verloren und jetzt das Rückspiel mit 0 zu 0 geradezu spektakulär gestaltet. Jeweils hatte man einen Expected-Goes-Wert von unter 0, 5 oder genau 0, 5. Was ist los bei Tottenham? In der Liga sieht es ja eigentlich noch halbwegs gut aus mit Rang 4.
Ja, von Tottenham reden wollen kann nicht die Rede sein, weil es echt keinen Spaß macht in der Saison. Es gab keine rote Karte für Konte, aber ansonsten gab es viel, viel Aufregung, weil er wie immer spricht und das sich sehr stark abnutzt. Und jetzt ist es so, dass die Situation von Konte bei Tottenham ziemlich sicher zu Ende geht, werden dann am Ende der Saison ganz genau 18 Monate gewesen sein, obwohl es sich anfühlt für mich wie vier Jahre Amtszeit bei den Spurs. Aber jetzt ist es auch so, dass inzwischen der Verein selbst auch nicht mehr mit Konte arbeiten will. Es war ja lange Zeit andersherum, dass Konte nie wollte und sich immer bitten ließ. Und jetzt sagt der Verein auch, nein, es ist jetzt gut. Jetzt lassen wir es und suchen uns einen anderen Trainer. Jetzt ist nur die Frage noch, die offen bleibt für die Saison. Und es geht sicherlich einher mit dem von dir schon angesprochenen Tabellenplatz. Reicht das für Platz 4? Glauben die Bosse wirklich daran, dass das gut geht? Dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie es vielleicht noch mit Acht und Krach durchziehen bis zum Ende der Saison. So wie Konte aber ganz häufig spricht und das schon teils vorbereitet, ist nicht ausgeschlossen. Dass es vielleicht nur noch ein paar Spiele werden und sich die Spurs dann doch noch mal irgendwie umgucken. Also sagen wir mal so, es sind doch maximal 11 Spiele für Konte als Spurs-Coach.
Das ist ja verrückt bei 4 Punkten Vorsprung auf Rang 5. Mario, wenn du das so hörst als Eselier A-Experte und ich meine, also man muss jetzt nicht alle Stationen drauf haben von Konte, aber dass er mal bei Atalanta war, bei Juve und italienischer Nationaltrainer plus Chelsea haben wir natürlich auch mitbekommen. Ich denke, das werden die Leute noch so drauf haben bei Interware dann danach später. Wenn ich mir das so angucke, dann war er nie besonders lange involviert bei den Teams. Erkennst du da jetzt Muster, wenn Uli so über Konte und Spurs spricht?
Ich finde ihn manchmal ein bisschen feige, ehrlich gesagt. Also bei ihm kam ja auch bei ihm, von ihm gibt es ja auch diesen Spruch, du kannst nicht mit 10 Euro in einem Luxus-Restaurant essen gehen. Er will halt immer, bei ihm ist immer ganz schnell, sind alle anderen schuld, die nicht vorhandenen Spieler, die er gerne hätte. Aber wenn man sich das Spiel gegen Milan anguckt, fand ich es auch wirklich erschreckend, wie wenig Offensivpower da von seinem Team vorhanden war. Da habe ich ihn jetzt in der Liga zu wenig verfolgt, aber das war irgendwie, als hätte da gar keine Entwicklung zu seinem sonstigen Spielstil stattgefunden. Und dann fand ich war eigentlich dieses Ausscheiden in der Champions League, wie Uli es schon gesagt hat, vielleicht der letzte Sargnagel für seine Zeit da.
Ja, war es denn auch offensiv so schlecht? Ich habe ja die Expected Goals schon zitiert, durchaus ein bisschen bitter, weil das Hinspiel habe ich nämlich auch noch im Second Screen gesehen. Und irgendwann fiel mir auf, dass ich da nie hingeguckt habe. Dann dachte ich mir, lag das jetzt an mir oder ist da einfach nichts passiert? Und dann habe ich mir die Statistiken angeguckt, da waren es irgendwie so eins zu zwei Schüsse nach 30 Minuten. Da dachte ich mir, es lag wahrscheinlich nicht an mir.
Es lag definitiv nicht an dir. Das war furchtbar. Das ist ein Heimspiel zu haben in der Champions League. Du bist ja absolut in Reichweite. Das ist jetzt keine Ausgangslage à la Frankfurt in Neapel, wo du ohnehin schon weißt, wir müssen schauen, dass wir schnellstmöglich ein Tor erzielen, um irgendwie die wenigstens Imagination noch am Leben zu halten. Sondern das war ja absolute Reichweite. Es hätte ja ein Tor sofort gereicht, um zumindest direkt die Verlängerung herzustellen. Und Milan war bei allem Respekt an beiden Abenden auch bestenfalls lala. Und was dann von Konting kam, war nichts. Und ich will jetzt in der Liga nicht so weit gehen, dass ich sage, das war offensiv absolut gar nichts. Es gab schon teilweise ordentliche Ansätze. Sie sind schon, was die abgesonderten Torschüsse angeht, oben mit dabei. Qualitativ nicht so sehr. Also das muss man dann noch mal einschränken. Aber, und das ist neu unter Conte, sie sind vor allen Dingen auch bei den kassierten Torschüssen ganz oben mit dabei. Auch da nicht in der Qualität. Aber erstmals in Contes Karriere gibt es im Schnitt 1, 4 Gegentore. Bislang waren es immer unter einem Gegentor. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Zum einen will ich ihn schon auch in Schutz nehmen. Der Kader ist nicht so breit und so stark, wie man denkt. Aber, und das muss man dann auch wiederum auf der anderen Seite sagen, er wusste ja, auf was er sich einlässt. Und er hat schon mehr bekommen als alle anderen Spurstrainer zusammen. Und es ist genügend Qualität da, um genügend Dinge zu machen. Warum läuft es in der Offensive nicht? Das ist das Spurs-Schicksal der letzten fünf Jahre. Die Abhängigkeit von Kane und Son ist ziemlich groß. Son performt überhaupt nicht in der Saison. Kane hat Phasen, in denen er immer mal wieder leicht müde wirkt. Das ist jetzt aber meckern auf hohem Niveau. Also ohne Harry Kane würden die wahrscheinlich auf Platz 10 stehen. Insofern, leichter Abrieb überall. Jetzt nach Mentern-Kurs-Verletzung ist auch gar keiner mehr da, der die Verbindung schafft zwischen Abwehr und Mittelfeld. Heuber ist ein fantastischer Spieler, aber kein Spielmacher sozusagen. Das sind so die Schnellgründe, warum es nicht läuft. Und dann halt dieses permanente Kontingent auf die Pressekonferenz und beschwert sich, widerspricht sich auch die ganze Zeit selbst. Ich habe das in unserem Podcast auch so gesagt, es passt aber, glaube ich, ganz gut. Wir alle hatten wahrscheinlich mal so einen Partner oder Partnerin, der oder die immer gesagt hat, wenn du das nicht machst, dann liebe ich dich nicht. Und Conte zieht das jetzt seit 18 Monaten durch und das ist langweilt einfach.
Ja, verrückt, wie sich auch so ein bisschen sein Ansehen jetzt dann doch gedreht hat, würde ich sagen, in den letzten Jahren. Aber lass mal von Conte ein bisschen wegkommen und mal über die Organisation Tottenham Hotspur sprechen, denn eigentlich ist da ja sehr viel passiert, das neue Stadion, die Ausrichtung, man hat ja auch Champions League Fußball gespielt, das war jetzt ja auch nicht immer selbstverständlich in den letzten Jahren. Wo stehen denn die Spurs in ihrer Entwicklung in dieser Liga?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich glaube, sie haben zwischenzeitlich ihren eigenen Wert und ihr eigenes Standing überschätzt, deswegen ja auch dieses Stadion, was sich Daniel Livia mehr oder weniger dann zur Lebensaufgabe gemacht hat, muss man ja auslassen, dass es ihm gelungen ist. Also, wenn mal da war, das ist schon okay, was da steht. Nichtsdestotrotz passt es natürlich weder in die Region, 7Sisters Tottenham rundherum rein, noch passt es auch zum Verein irgendwie rein und noch geht es einher mit den sportlichen Leistungen. Das Problem bei den Spurs, aus meiner Sicht, war immer, das sackt sich natürlich leicht und so eine Kultur muss ja auch wachsen, aber das ist jetzt auch so. Das Dabeisein in der Champions League ist viel, viel wichtiger und nimmt sieben Achtel der Überlegungen als das Abschneiden in der Champions League. Und das verstehe ich immer nicht so sehr. Es gibt jetzt ein paar Sachen, wie man das deuten kann. Also Daniel Levy war immer jemand, der gerade im Auswählen von Funktionären ein supergoldenes Händchen hatte. Das ging dann aber schief, als er Pochettino entließ, wobei ich das zum gewissen Grad damals noch verstehen konnte. Aber seither haben sie ganz viel Geld und Zeit verschwendet und haben verschiedene Richtungen eingeschlagen. Das zeigt mir auch, dass sie nicht genau wissen, wer sie sind. Weil dann nehmen sie Jose Mourinho. Das alles an Mourinho hat mir gesagt, okay, sie denken, sie sind jetzt so weit, dass sie gewinnen können. Haben dann den Kader total umgestellt, sind älter geworden, haben sehr viel mehr auf Mentalität, auf Robustheit gesetzt, in Käufen, haben durchaus für ihre Verhältnisse auch ein wenig Geld ausgegeben, ohne dann auch wieder all in zu gehen. Und dann geht Mourinho weg und sie dümpeln. Witzigerweise vor dem Pokalfinale lassen sie Mourinho 11 Tage vorher gehen. Auch das kann man irgendwie verstehen, zeigt aber auch, wo ist eure Idee. Dann kommt Ryan Mason, das funktioniert vor und hinten nicht für ein paar Wochen, der jetzt immer noch im Trainerstab ist. Und dann geht es weiter und sie holen sich im Sommer Korb für Korb ab auf dem Trainermarkt. Selbst Zweitligatrainer sagen, nein, danke, da will ich nicht hin. Und dann kommt Nuno Espirito Santo. Das ist kompletter Quatsch gewesen, diese Verpflichtung. Und das zeigt aber wiederum, sie sind immer noch eigentlich europäisch bestenfalls drittklassig. Weil Nuno Espirito Santo war vorher der Coach der portugiesischen Benationalmannschaft bei den Wolves. Und dann geht es weiter und weiter und sie suchen. Und jetzt ist ja auch wieder so. Wenn man jetzt die Trainer-Shortlist sich anseht, da sind Namen drauf, die scheinen realistisch für mich zu sein. Und dann sind Namen drauf, wo man denkt, was dringt ihr da in Norden-Londons? Das wird nie passieren. Und deswegen kann ich dir die Frage nur unzureichend beantworten, weil ich glaube, der Verein selber weiß auch nicht ganz genau, wer er ist. Manchmal leben sie die Verhältnisse und manchmal vergleichgültigen sie sich selber ein wenig.
Das ist ja echt einigermaßen absurd, aber man konnte es ja an den Transfers ehrlicherweise in den letzten Jahren schon immer sehen. Da waren auch immer gute Transfers mit dabei. Jemand wie M'Bantako zum Beispiel hast ja schon erwähnt, dass der ausfährt, das merkt man dann. Und dann sieht man ja, welche Rolle er dann auch schon relativ schnell gespielt hat. Aber es waren auch viele so Transfers dabei, wo ich hätte dann quasi anfangen müssen, dem nochmal hinterher zu googeln. Und das ist dann quasi das Zeichen dafür, also so ganz bekannt waren die Spieler jetzt nicht immer. Und das kann dann zwar auch, kann auch dafür sprechen, dass sie nicht auf große Namen gehen. Aber – und ist es ja auch so – aber sportlich eben sieht man dann eben kaum was. Dann ist es eben doch immer Kane und Son und eben eine Defensive, die aber jetzt aktuell nicht mehr steht. Also die Spurs. Wir gucken, wie lange Antonio Conte das schafft und ob sich diese, dieser Verein irgendwann unter Daniel Levy, ob die sich dann ein bisschen definieren irgendwann. Aber naja, haben wir ja noch ein paar Jahre, das zu beobachten. Und dann hast du noch ein Thema mitgebracht und da könnte nämlich auch ein Trainerwechsel vielleicht anstehen. Du möchtest über Crystal Palace noch sprechen. Ich habe da natürlich flugs nachgeguckt. Ja, wann hat denn Crystal Palace zuletzt gewonnen? Denn in der Tabelle sieht das alles noch halbwegs okay aus. Rang 12. Allerdings muss man auch sagen, nur drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsplatz. Und dann guckt man sich die letzten Spiele an und sieht, Niederlage 0-1, 0-1, 0-1, okay, unentschieden, unentschieden, unentschieden. Letzter Sieg am 31. Dezember gegen Bournemouth. Gegen die sollte man dann auch gewinnen. Also, außer man ist jetzt Liverpool. Aber ansonsten haben jetzt viele gegen die gewonnen. Ist es quasi eine Formkrise, die da das Problem ist? Oder warum wackelt da auch ein Trainerstuhl?
Ja, Formkrise einerseits. Ich glaube aber andererseits vor allen Dingen Identitätskrise, weil Patrick Viara in der letzten Saison mit einfachsten Mitteln einen sehr effektiven Spielstil hat prägen lassen. Der ist inzwischen vollends ausgerechnet, was auch nicht schwierig ist. Und jetzt merkt man, dass der Trainer samt Team offensichtlich nicht so sehr den vollen Plan hat, wie er dieses Team weiterzuentwickeln hat. Also, jetzt, dass es so dick kommt, ergebnistechnisch, wie es gerade kommt, ist blöd, läuft dumm. Daher auch schon sicherlich vorm Einbußen, aber alles in allem war es fast absehbar, dass, wenn sie nicht ganz schnell was dazu tun zu ihrem Spielstil, dann wird das nichts werden. Das ist wirklich – das ist par excellence – eine reine Kontermannschaft, eine reine Gegenpressingmannschaft. Und wenn das nicht läuft, dann haben die gar nichts. Also, Ball am Fuß ist wirklich – da sind sie hands down das schwächste Team der Liga.
Krass. Und wie wird das da gesehen? Ich meine, Crystal Palace hat eine große Tradition, aber keiner von uns hätte jetzt erwartet, dass die irgendwie im oberen Tabellen-Drittel auf jeden Fall fix mit dabei sind. Wie ist die Stimmung vor Ort?
Also, ich glaube, das ist auch Grund, dessen, warum Patrick Viera noch im Amt ist, dass die Spitze bei Crystal Palace weiß, dass sie in der letzten Saison leicht überperformt haben. Ansonsten wäre er schon weg. Nichtsdestotrotz hat man sich schon bei Crystal Palace irgendwie gewünscht, dass man einen Schritt macht, weil sie ganz schön Geld in die Mannschaft investiert haben, seit Roy Hodgson da weg war. Vielleicht muss man es auch von daher noch mal sehen, woher man kommt sozusagen und welchen Fußball man mal gespielt hat. Dahin hat man sich schon entwickelt. Das ist also schon mal ganz okay. Aber seit Hodgson weg ist, hat man die Mannschaft verjüngt. Man hat einige der interessantesten jungen Einzelspieler wenigstens im ganzen Land, auch englischer Nationalität im Kader. Deshalb kann man sich das immer ganz gut anschauen. Man hat aber sicherlich es nicht geschafft, einfach mal ein paar Spezialisten da einzuziehen. Der Kader ist ziemlich ähnlich gebaut. Ahamada zum Beispiel von VfB Stuttgart ist ja da im Winter jetzt hingewechselt. Da hat mich sofort ein Kollege, der Crystal Palace, täglich sozusagen verfolgt, verständigt und gesagt, er ist doch der nächste Box-to-Box-Spieler. Tja, ich weiß. Oh Gott, wo will dieser Patrick wieder rein? Will er sich selber einfach 16 mal im Kader haben, nur in der Light-Version? Und die Antwort ist ja.
Ja, ja, interessanter Gedanke. So habe ich da noch gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Er reproduziert ein bisschen seine sportliche Karriere. Und gibt es – also ich meine, die Gefahr gibt es natürlich, dass Crystal noch weiter unten reinrutscht. Wie blickst du denn insgesamt auf diese Situation in der Liga, dass wir in der Premier League aktuell wirklich eine zweigeteilte Tabelle haben? Also Aston Villa auf Rang 11, 35 Punkte. Palace dahinter auf Rang 12, 27 Punkte. Und ab da beginnt die Abstiegszone, denn es wird bis zum Platz 20 nur bis zu 22 Punkte sinken. Das heißt, alles unheimlich eng beieinander, haben wir ja auch in der letzten Folge ja schon angesprochen.
Ja, ich tue mich so schwer, dieses Jahr wirklich vorherzusagen, wer absteigt. Also tue ich mich vor der Saison ehrlicherweise auch schon immer, weil es einfach hohe Qualitäten sind, die da in den Kader jeweils rumlaufen. Aber es ist schon, man merkt aber dann auch, das ist in etwa auch finanziell der Schnitt. Ein, zwei Teams geraten unten mit rein, die ähnlich investieren wie die, die dann ab Villa nach oben losgehen. Aber grundsätzlich ist das auch der finanzielle Schnitt, der gemacht werden muss. Und das ist ja auch Teil der Wahrheit. Und ich will jetzt da gar niemanden anzählen. Die Namen, die ich gleich aufzähle, die sind ja in unser aller Herzen wahrscheinlich drin. Die Gerrards, die Lampards, die Villarras, das waren ja fantastische Fußballspieler, machen aber als Trainer offensichtlich nicht den Unterschied. Die sind als Fußballpersönlichkeiten wahrscheinlich zu gut, zu clever, um etwas völlig in den Sand zu setzen. Also außer Frank Lampard vielleicht. Und sind aber zu schwach, um als Trainer Unterschiede zu machen und wirklich sich zu adaptieren an das aktuelle Spiel. Die Vereine, die sie aber auswählen als Trainer, Everton, da jetzt Essen will, aber die haben zu viel Geld und zu viel Qualität im Kader, und auch Crystal Palace und so, die sind halt teilweise noch traditionell anderswo unterwegs als zum Beispiel das Positivbeispiel Brighton of Albion, die halt mal außerhalb der Box denken, Roberto de Zerbi holen und mich damit für immer in ihren Bein gezogen haben.
Das denkt aber wie Ra auch, wenn er Box-to-Box-Spieler holt. Streng genommen. Nämlich von der einen Box zu anderen. Also ich verstehe, was du meinst. Brighton hat aktuell zwei Punkte hinter Rang 5 auf Rang 7. Also das ist gerade ganz anders. Ich musste da – da muss ich jetzt wieder den Mario mit reinhören – ehemalige Spieler, die als Trainer übernehmen und wir sehen, okay, das funktioniert hier trotz großer Namen auf der Trainerbank nicht so gut. In Italien irgendwie ein bisschen besser oder ist das jetzt arg momentaufnahmenmäßig von mir gedacht?
Ja, es ist schon eine Momentaufnahme, würde ich sagen. Aber da haben ein paar in den letzten Jahren, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen mehr Zeit bekommen, als sie sonst vielleicht in den Jahren davor bekommen hätten. Es ist so eine Mutmaßung, wo sich dann immer wieder herausstellt, dass eine gewisse Konstanz auch da auf der Trainerbank und gemeinsames Arbeiten mit einer Philosophie, sie vielleicht auch Milan mit Piolli und Maldini zusammen, dann auszahlt. Ich bin ein großer Fan davon, dass das so in Fußballverein oder Fußball-Franchise gehandhabt wird und es zahlt sich dann doch irgendwann wieder aus. Und deswegen ist jetzt vielleicht jetzt gerade die Momentaufnahme so eine extrem positive aus italienischer Sicht.
Ja, es ist vielleicht auch ganz interessant, Alexi mal dazu zu hören. Ich kann mich erinnern, vor ein paar Jahren als Nizza in der Europa League gegen Leverkusen gespielt hat, haben wir gesprochen und du hast mir damals schon gesagt, dass es in den ersten eineinhalb, zwei Jahren ganz gut aussah und dann hat man eine gewisse Planlosigkeit gemerkt. Ich erkenne jetzt gewisse Parallelen bei Crystal Palace, Patrik, wie er aber vielleicht kannst du einfach nochmal aus der Zeit damals bei Nizza berichten.
Ja, ich glaube, es hat nicht mal Jahre gedauert bzw. nach ein paar Monaten war es für ihn schon, oder er hat den Eindruck vermittelt, dass er seinen Kader nicht mehr im Griff hatte und dann auch, was er spielerisch oder seine Mannschaft angeboten hat, war einfach viel zu wenig bzw. auch nicht schön. Das war nur defensiv, nur zerstörend und da hat man sich schon gefragt, was macht eigentlich Werra da, nachdem eine gewisse Euphorie herrschte, als er verpflichtet wurde an der Côte d'Azur, weil er natürlich einen großen Namen hat und einiges vorhatte. Aber dann hat man gemerkt, vielleicht liegt ihm England besser. Ich hätte auch gedacht, dass er bei Crystal Palace, obwohl die erste Saison noch eine Hälfte war, okay, ich war ja einmal im Selhurst-Prague im Oktober gegen Wolverhampton, so privat dort, und man hatte schon das Gefühl, dass er auch mal wie vor sehr beliebt ist bei den Fans und vielleicht der richtige Verein für ihn ist, um wieder Kredit persönlich zu verschaffen nach seiner schlechten Erfahrung bei Nietsa. Aber man merkt schon, dass er zum Beispiel große Mannschaften, wie du gesagt hast vorher Uli, über Gérard oder Lempard, ob die sich auf dem höchsten Level durchsetzen könnten. Weil Angie Rath zum Beispiel war ja schon längst als Klub-Nachfolger gefeiert, irgendwann mal in Liverpool, aber ist es immer noch aktuell oder? Ich glaube nicht daran, dass es stimmt, aber im Gerücht hieß auch, dass er der Nachfolger von Galtier in Paris wird in diesem Sommer. Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Spieler oder Ex-Spieler, Ex-Superstars das Zeug haben, dauerhaft sich durchzusetzen und was Gérard durchmacht jetzt seit Januar, wo die Ergebnisse gar nicht mehr stimmen, ob er auf dem höchsten Niveau wirklich für Begeisterung sorgen kann. Wenn er sich schon mal bei Niza und vor allem bei Crystal Palace nicht durchsetzt, dann braucht er nicht von Arsenal zum Beispiel irgendwann zu träumen.
Vielleicht ein kleiner Vergleich dazu auch aus Italien, wenn man sich das da anguckt. Pipo Insagi, der deutlich erfolgreichere Spieler gewesen, als Trainer nicht so gut wie sein Bruder Simone. Er ist zwar wieder im Aufstiegsrennen in der Serie B mit Regina, aber immer wenn er in der Serie A war, ist es dann auch irgendwie von kurzer Dauer gewesen. Und andererseits, das spricht wieder für dieses Thema Momentaufnahme und bisschen Spielglück, Simone bei Inter, wenn der jetzt gegen Porto rausgegangen wäre, am Wochenende ist Juve, ist der Stuhl schon auch sehr wackelig da gewesen. Und jetzt hat er aber wieder das Narrativ auf seiner Seite, dass er ins Viertelfinale gekommen ist.
Ja, das kommt natürlich immer noch mal mit dazu. Ich glaube, da werden wir gleich mal noch mal ausführlicher drüber sprechen, über Champions League und italienische Teams. Vorher verabschieden wir aber Uli Hebel, denn der muss jetzt wahrscheinlich die Eckballvarianten in Bournemouth noch mal genau unter die Lupe nehmen. Uli, danke dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für die Ligatur und bis bald mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk.
Sehr gerne, viel Spaß euch noch.
So, und dann machen wir doch direkt weiter, Mario, denn du hast es als eins deiner Themen mitgebracht, dass die Serie A sehr erfolgreich in der Champions League ist. Und zwar genau genommen ist es die erfolgreichste Champions League-Saison der Liga seit 17 Jahren. Gleichzeitig hast du aber ja gerade auch schon von Spielglück gesprochen. Also auch hier Momentaufnahme oder größere Entwicklung?
Beides, würde ich sagen. Also seit 17 Jahren ist es zum ersten Mal drei Teams im Viertelfinale der Champions League. Wir hatten in den letzten vier Jahren vier unterschiedliche Meister. Das finde ich was auch für eine Entwicklung oder die Klasse in der Liga spricht. In Italien haben sie selber den höchsten Zuschauerschnitt der letzten 20 Jahre. Also das finde ich geht schon in eine richtige Richtung und das finde ich fußballerisch gesehen auch viel besser anzuschauen noch als vor ein paar Jahren. Aber gerade Inter hat dieses Jahr eigentlich sehr zu kämpfen, die ich vom Kader her, von der Breite her, von der Qualität eigentlich sogar noch am wettbewerbsfähigsten auch in der Königsklasse betrachtet hätte. Und jetzt muss man sagen, dass die eigentlich von den drei Teams, also Napoli und Milan, sind die anderen zwei vermutlich das leichteste Los ist für die anderen Gegner, wenn die dann noch kommen sollten. Also da ist es schon noch ein bisschen Momentaufnahmen, wenn man sich die letzten Minuten in Porto anschaut, haben sie da großen Dusel gehabt, dass sie da mit einem schönen italienischen 1-0 hinspielen und 0-0, also dem 90er Jahre italienischen Fußball sozusagen, da weitergekommen sind. Also da ist, glaube ich, immer noch nicht alles Gold, was glänzt, aber die Entwicklung ist, finde ich, deutlich zu erkennen, dass die in die richtige Richtung geht.
Aber kann man denn jetzt schon sagen, woran das liegt? Ist das nur, in Anführungszeichen, nur, weil die Dominanz von Juve mal aufgebrochen wurde oder liegt es an italienischen Talenten? Ich meine, die Nationalmannschaft hat jetzt zwar nicht so erfolgreich abgeschnitten, das wissen wir ja, aber auch da haben wir ja das Zustandekommen des Ausscheidens oder der Nicht-WM-Teilnahme ja auch gesehen. Da kommen halt auch manchmal dann Kleinigkeiten miteinander zusammen. Also, was hat sich da im Größeren verändert?
Also, ich denke, der Einbruch der Juvedominanz ist schon auch mit ein Faktor. Das hat sicherlich auch für ein anderes Selbstverständnis wieder von den anderen Vereinen gesorgt. Inter hatte eine Zeit lang auch massiv Geld zur Verfügung, hat gut investiert, also sie dann eben auch mit Kontenmeister geworden sind. Italienische Talente würde ich in Klammern setzen, wenn wir uns – glaube ich, das war jetzt beim Champions-League-Spiel Mielandes, da waren die ersten elf Spieler keiner mit einem italienischen Pass. Also das ist schon auch was, was im Land selber kritisch gesehen wird, gerade in Hinblick auf die Entwicklung der Nationalmannschaft. Das muss man deutlich so sagen. Aber wie vorhin schon einmal angedeutet, ich finde, einige Vereine, gerade Milan und Napoli, da rauszustellen, haben extrem gute, auch mit etwas mehr Weitblick, Transferarbeit und Managementarbeit und Strukturen des Katars gesteckt, was, glaube ich, in den Jahren davor auch mit der Juve-Dominanz oft nicht der Fall war. Also bei Juve ist es ja selber immer noch ein bisschen so, dass da das waren Vereine, die nie einen Umbruch oder einen sogenannten Rebuild dann mit mit jungen Spielern angestrebt haben, sondern dann eher halt einen Pogba holen. Dann ist Rabiot über mehrere Wochen der beste Spieler von Juve. Das finde ich, also ohne dem zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber das spricht so ein bisschen für sich. Und dann gibt es aber auch andere Vereine, die jetzt in der Champions League vielleicht nicht die Rolle spielen. Dann schauen wir uns Lazio an mit Sarri zum Beispiel, der da auch einige für Außenstehende vielleicht No-Names geholt hat, aber auch über mehrere Jahre jetzt sozusagen Spieler, die zu ihm, zu seinem Fußballstil passen geholt hat und jetzt auch wieder in den ersten vier um die Champions League mitspielt und nicht direkt wie bei Juve nach einem Jahr, weil er mit CR7 nicht zurecht kam, dann wieder da geschasst wurde, weil eben irgendwie der Plan immer nur für die nächsten sechs Monate gilt. Ich finde, das ist deutlich zu bemerken.
Mario, ich hätte da eine Frage kurz zu dem Spieler von Milan, der den nicht so ein bisschen verfolglich aus spanischer Sicht ist. Das ist Brahim Dias, der hier in Malaga geboren worden ist und hier die Jugendabteilungen durchlaufen hat, dann zu Guardiola, zu Man City, ist dann über Real Madrid, den Umweg jetzt zu Milan gefunden hat und dort jetzt gerade, glaube ich, so richtig durchstartet, oder?
Der hat auf jeden Fall eine Entwicklung genommen, die auch als positiv zu bewerten ist. Ich finde, der hat eine viel größere, wenn du ihn damals vielleicht auch verfolgt hast, ich finde sein Problem war oft, dass er keine Ruhe am Ball ausgestrahlt hat, damit er sich auch in Situationen gebracht hat, in denen er deswegen in der Entscheidungsfindung der Spielübersicht arge Defizite hatte, was er in seiner Position schon auch im offensiven Mittelfeld oder so ein bisschen fluide da rumturnend nicht allzu unwichtig ist, möchte ich mal meinen. Das gelingt ihm jetzt immer besser, hat aber trotzdem immer noch seine Auf und Abs, hat aber in jedem Fall profitiert davon, dass in der Mannschaft eine gute Mischung aus Jung und Alt herrscht und glaube ich, da auch viele um ihn herum, gerade auch Ibra, der ein wichtiger Faktor war, das hat man gemerkt, als er verletzt war, dass er schon ein bisschen mehr war als nur ein Maskottchen. Davon hat er sehr profitiert. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass die Entwicklung von Brahim Dias noch nicht ganz am Ende ist und man dem in den nächsten Jahren noch ganz gut beim Fußballspielen zugucken kann, ja.
Ja, man hat auf jeden Fall den Eindruck, dass es besser jetzt für ihn passt, bei Man City und Real. Das war wahrscheinlich noch ein Schritt zu schnell nach oben. Und jetzt bei Milan, glaube ich, kann er sich ganz gut entwickeln und reinfinden. Und ich habe es noch mitbekommen, er hat auch wichtige Tore jetzt geschossen und so weiter. Und ist eigentlich schon so eine Art Stammspieler geworden bei Milan, oder?
Ja, definitiv. Das muss man sagen. Ich glaube, das ist gut von dir zusammengefasst da auch, dass vielleicht der eine große Schritt einer zu früh kam. Und jetzt vor allem auch Pioli, ein Trainer war, der sehr gut mit dieser Altersmischung in der Mannschaft umgegangen ist und sich da, glaube ich, auch viele Spieler, die zuvor nicht ganz groß die Vertrauensflagge hießen konnten, da ihre Persönlichkeit auch entwickelt haben.
Mario, wenn wir jetzt im größeren Rahmen über die Serie A sprechen und ich mir allein den letzten Spieltag angucke, da gewinnt Spezia gegen Inter am Freitag mit 2 zu 1. Deswegen Cannapoli, die gegen Bergamo mit 2 zu 0 gewinnen, auf 18 Punkte Vorsprung davon rauschen. Wir sehen ein 4 zu 2 von Juve gegen Sampdoria, die sich aber richtig schwergetan haben. Also da musste quasi Juve zurückkommen. Milan spielt 1 zu 1 gegen Salahnitana. Und die Roma verliert zu Hause mit 3 zu 4 gegen Sassuolo. Ist das gerade die spannendste Liga der Europas? Ich meine, Uli ist jetzt schon raus. Der kann jetzt für die Premier League nicht widersprechen, aber wir haben ja gerade schon gehört, was für ein fürchterlicher Fußball da gespielt wird. In der unteren Tabellenhälfte oder auch hier im Moment Aufnahme. Hat sich da was grundlegend verändert?
Ich finde, da hat sich schon grundlegend was verändert. Also es gibt so ein paar Vereine. Sassuolo hat es gerade einmal angesprochen, dass ja auch der Verein bei dem De Zerbi groß geworden ist. Ein hochspannender Klub, bei dem reicht es so, von der Konstanz ja nicht oben mitzuspielen. Aber solche Spiele wie gegen die Roma zeigen eigentlich, was da immer schon für eine erfrischende Spielidee auch gelebt wird. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Hoffenheim Italiens, keine große Fanbase, nicht gewachsen über mehrere Jahre, sondern so ein bisschen aus dem Boden gestampft, aber immer mit einer Idee junge Spieler zu holen, die die Philosophie passen, junge spannende Trainer. Ganz kurz die Frage mit der Spannendsten ist jetzt natürlich, dadurch, dass Napoli so enteilt ist und bei der Meisterschaft nicht der Fall ist.
Ja, lustig, dass ich das völlig ignoriert habe.
Aber das mit den vier unterschiedlichen Meistern in den letzten vier Jahren, hatte ich ja schon gesagt. Und ansonsten haben sie wirklich, klar, auch alte Trainer wie Spalletti, die aber eben einen extrem offensiv getriebenen und spannenden Fußball spielen lassen. Aber auch im Tabellen-Mittelfeld leider, finde ich, unter den Erwartungen geblieben. Trotzdem ein gutes Kader hier. Die Fiorentina ist auch europäisch noch vertreten. Vincenzo Italiano, auch ein junger, ich sage mal, das Wort ist immer negativ behaftet. Aber ich sage es jetzt mal positiv, Konzept-Trainer, der sicherlich, glaube ich, auch in den nächsten Jahren, wenn er sich nicht komplett sozusagen als Heimscheiße identifiziert, vielleicht auch noch einer für eine andere große europäische Liga ist. Und das lässt, finde ich, die Breite in der Serie A, also wenn man die ersten, die unter den drei, vier Vereine ausklammert, ist das schon, finde ich, auch immer eine Tatsache, die eine Liga sehr interessant macht. Denn, sagen wir mal, du schaust ja gerne alle Spiele am Wochenende in der Bundesliga, da sind ja auch Spielpaarungen dabei.
Wir wissen alle, was du sagen willst und das ist korrekt. Ja, ist ja also eine sehr positive Entwicklung und auch glückliche Fügung, dass du jetzt zusammen mit Marius zusammen den Serie Amore Podcast gestartet hast. Also ja nicht jetzt, sondern ja schon vor einiger Zeit. Aber da seid ihr in ein gutes Zeitfenster hineingekommen, möchte ich mal behaupten. Auf jeden Fall gutes Timing. Kann man sich jeden Spieltag sehr gut angucken. Ein bisschen anders ist es in der Ligue 1, ohne jetzt gleich über die ganze Liga urteilen zu wollen. Aber, Alexi, wir sprechen immer viel über PSG, wenn wir über die Ligue 1 sprechen. Man kommt ja auch nicht dran vorbei und gleichzeitig reden wir aber immer wieder über dieselben Probleme. PSG schafft nicht den großen Erfolg auf europäische Übende und national gewinnt man die Liga mit einigem Vorsprung. Auch jetzt ist man ja wieder 10 Punkte voraus vor Marseille, die jetzt so ein kleines Tal durchlaufen in den letzten Pflichtspielen. Du hast mir jetzt angekündigt, dass du mir jetzt endgültig mal erklärst, warum die Stars bei PSG ihr Potenzial in die Aufrufung und dann aber an anderen Orten auftrumpfen. Jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt. Woran liegt es? Ist es die Pariser Luft?
Womöglich, ja. Und das Nachtleben. Es gibt halt so viele Beispiele, wo Spieler kommen und haben so einen hohen Marktwert und sind alles Hoffnungsträger. Und dann liefern die nicht mehr bei PSG. Du hast natürlich aus deutscher Sicht den Julian Draxler als bestes Beispiel, der ja für 38 Millionen damals, glaube ich, 2017 aus Wolfsburg kam und dachte, er startet jetzt eine fantastische Karriere und er hat in fünf Jahren eineinhalb gute Spiele gehabt. Und dann hast du vielleicht das beste Beispiel, kann mich wahrscheinlich der Mario bestätigen, Weinaldum, der auch mit großer Hoffnung aus Liverpool kam, bei PSG nur ein Phantom war, nie sein Potenzial ausschöpfen konnte und jetzt bei der Roma, nach seiner langen Verletzung, wieder fast Fuß immer besser wird und wichtige Rolle spielt und man fragt sich, warum diese Spieler bei PSG gar nicht liefern. Natürlich hat das mit dem Druck zu tun, der ist immens, dann hat das damit zu tun, dass die drei Außerirdischen vorne, Neymar, Messi und Mbappe, die anderen Spieler irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass sie halt nicht ihr Potenzial ausschöpfen, weil sie einfach dermaßen polarisieren und alles dominieren in dem Kader, in der Kabine, dass sich diese Spieler nicht befreien, nicht aufspielen können, nicht befreit spielen können und das ist bei allen Spielern, die gerade ausgeliehen sind, wie Draxler, wie Icardi, der auch bei Galatasaray auf einmal Tore wie am Fließband schießt und alle diese Spieler kommen jetzt im Sommer zurück und da sind wir alle gespannt, wie es dann weitergeht, aber es ist schon ein großes Problem, wenn die Spieler nach Paris kommen, gibt es zu viel Geld, Ich glaube, es ist zu viel Geld, zu viele interessante Sachen neben dem Platz, aber auch in der Mannschaft passt es nicht, weil du halt drei Ausnahmen daraus hast, plus der Rest. Und dieser Rest fühlt sich einfach nicht wohl, weil irgendwie angespannt durch das Auftreten und die Attitüden der MNM.
Und gleichzeitig ja auch ein Spielstil. Ich meine, das haben wir jetzt ja in der Champions League gegen Bayern sehen können. Also Bayern wollte nicht in der ersten Hälfte, deswegen haben die auf Offensivspiel verzichtet. Und dadurch, dass man sich aber dann nicht hat locken lassen und es eben nicht die Räume zum Kontern gab, kam von PSG ja wirklich auch sehr wenig. Also beide Teams waren offensiv ganz fürchterlich schlecht. Nur bei den einen konnte man wenigstens noch so sagen, ja wahrscheinlich war das aber quasi Teil des Plans, jetzt erstmal nichts anzubieten. Das ist ja jetzt keine ganz neue Erkenntnis, wenn man PSG viel öfter sieht, so wie du. Warum hat es denn jetzt egal welcher Trainer in den letzten Jahren, und ich meine, wir reden ja hier auch mit Gartier über jemanden, der wird auch nicht mehr Trainer bleiben bei PSG, wird jetzt niemanden über Raschenmänner ausgewechselt wird, warum hat das keiner hinbekommen? Liegt das auch an der Situation, wie dann vielleicht auch Sportdirektoren und andere Menschen noch mit reinreden wollen in die Aufstellung und Kadergestaltung ja sowieso?
Das Hauptproblem ist immer das Gleiche seit Jahren. Erst einmal, dass der Präsident Nasser Al-Khalifi heißt, der vom Fußball gar keine Ahnung hat, aber vom Scheich, also von seinem Chef, der in Doha weilt, einfach immer geschützt wird. Und Al-Khalifi schweigt seitdem aus in München, keine neue Erkenntnis von ihm. Wenn es schlecht läuft, versteckt er sich. Wenn es gut läuft, wie zuletzt beim 3-0 in Marseille, dann steht er in der Mix-Sonne auf einmal zur Verfügung. Das kann einfach nicht sein und er ist dafür verantwortlich, dass ein Spieler früher Neymar, dann Messi und heute Mbappé, über den Verein steht, über die Institutionen, die es gar nicht gibt. Und solange die Verantwortlichen aus Doha nicht verstehen, dass kein Spieler der Welt, kein Trainer der Welt über den Verein stehen darf, dann werden sie in der Champions League ja für nach wie vor scheitern bzw. enttäuschen. Wir sind heute so weit weg von Champions League Triumph, weil einfach alles nicht stimmt in dem Verein an sich. Jetzt hört man auch immer wieder Gerüchte, dass ein katholischer Gruppe, aber eigentlich die gleiche Gruppe wie PSG, Manchester United, kaufen soll. Was passiert da mit PSG, mit dieser Mannschaft von heute? Warum hat man vor zwei Jahren Neymar einen neuen Fährungsvertrag gegeben? Wofür? Wenn er schon mal nicht in der Lage ist, die Hälfte der Spiele zu bestreiten, weil er ständig nachts unterwegs ist und angetrunken zum Training kommt und dann sich zufällig wieder verletzt, wieder an derselben Stelle. Bei 36 Millionen Netto im Jahr ist das natürlich eine Katastrophe, auch wenn es ein Trinkgeld ist für Katar. Warum holt man Messi so spät, der eh keinen Illustrat auf Paris und eine katastrophale Einstellung hat mit gesenktem Kopf in jedem Spiel und nur kassieren will? Der einzige, der da herausragt, ist Mbappé. Aber du musst eine Mannschaft um ihn bauen. Trotzdem, wenn Messi und Neymar nicht mehr da sein sollen, dann ist Mbappé dort noch da und er steht über den Verein. Das ist nach wie vor ein Eigentor. Das wollen Sie nicht verstehen bei Paris Saint-Germain. Auch nicht an den zwei Spielen gegen die Bayern, die für ihn und für Peugeot ein tolles Beispiel sein sollen, wie man einen Verein führt, das dort strukturiert und höchst professionell gearbeitet wird. Deswegen gab es bei Bayern in diesen Jahrzehnten, dass man auf dem höchsten Level in Europa so gut wie nie enttäuscht eigentlich.
Alexi, wie siehst du da aktuell die Rolle von Verratti? Das wäre in meinem Verständnis eigentlich ein Spieler, der für so etwas auch sorgen könnte, für Engagement und Zusammenhalt auf dem Platz, sowohl spielerisch als auch mental gesehen.
Ich finde, es ist wieder eine Katastrophe, dass man ihn verlängert, weil er für ihr enttäuscht, weil er in einem großen Spiel nicht mehr auf der Höhe ist, seine 3 Schachtel Zigaretten am Tag raucht. Mit solchen Spielern kannst du nicht Champions-League-Sieger werden. Aber jetzt nach der WM dachten wir, weil er sich erholen konnte, weil Italien nicht dabei war in Katar, dass er der beste Verratti aller Zeiten wird. Was passiert, da verletzt sich wieder aus dem Nichts und liefert auch danach keine gute Leistung an gegen die Bayern. Er war unterdurchschnittlich in einer Rolle, in der man schon hofft, dass er Paris auf einem anderen Niveau hilft. Er bringt einfach viel zu wenig. Er ist einfach froh und glücklich in Paris, hat da sein Restaurant gekauft. Wenn er seine paar Champions-League-Spiele im Jahr macht, ist er zufrieden. Aber du hast nicht das Gefühl, zumindest seit zwei, drei Jahren, einen ganz großen Willen, die Champions League gewinnen zu wollen, seit der Finalniederlage gegen die Bayern damals in Lissabon, hat man das Gefühl, er ist satt, er ist einfach satt. Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, dass man mit Spielern wie Viverati, wie Marquinhos immer wieder verlängert, weil die sind genau das Zeichen des Scheiterns in den letzten Jahren. Nicht zu vergessen, diese Schmach von Peugeot letztes Jahr gegen Real ausgeschieden, obwohl man in drei von vier Halbzeiten die Club-Essay-Mannschaft war, damals gegen Manchester United, die C-Mannschaft von Manchester United ausgeschieden, wieder im Achtelfinale und natürlich 2017 4-0 im Hinspiel gewonnen gegen Barca, 1-6 im Rückspiel mit drei Gegentoren in der Nachspielzeit. Also, peinlicher geht es nicht mehr.
Ja, also in der Summe dann schon. Ich meine, es haben ja immer dann quasi individuelle Entscheidungen da auch noch eine Rolle gespielt. Die Momentaufnahme mit Champions League hat ja vorhin Mario schon angesprochen. Also, könnten ja noch mal über Dennis Aitekin. War das doch, glaube ich, der da diesen Strahstoß gegeben hat bei Barca gegen PG? Es sind so kleinere Themen, aber im Großen sieht man ja dann doch eine größere Entwicklung. Aber es wundert mich, dass dir nicht klar ist, was Nasser Al-Khelaifi gerade macht, weil es ist doch völlig eindeutig. Der übernimmt jetzt den FC Malaga. Der spielt gerade in der zweiten spanischen Liga, steht da auf dem drittletzten Platz, aber ist dennoch – und das musst du mir jetzt erklären, Fabian – ist dennoch angeblich ein Objekt der Begierde von Katar.
Ja, und es liegt sogar ein bisschen auf der Hand, warum. Weil der FC Malaga ja noch einen Präsidenten hat, der auch aus Katar kommt und der auch zur Königsfamilie in Katar gehört und irgendwie auch mit Al-Kelayfi anscheinend verwandt ist, über eine Ecke Eken. Das ist der Schaij Al-Tani. Und ja, das Problem beim FC Malaga ist ja nur, seit 2020, dass Al-Tani gar nicht mehr Präsident ist, zumindest ausübender ist. Ja, dem wurden seine Aktienanteile erst mal beschlagnahmt wegen Misswirtschaft, wegen Korruption, wegen verschiedenen Geschichten. Und seitdem wird der FC Malaga von einem gerichtlich oder juristisch eingesetzten Geschäftsführer geführt. Und es ist aber so, dass Al-Tani seine Aktienanteile zurückbekommen könnte, wenn er die Riesensumme von 9 Millionen Euro hinterlegt. Riesensumme natürlich in Anführungszeichen, weil für einen Katari ist das natürlich eigentlich nichts. Aber für Al-Tani eben schon. Der ist so ein bisschen das schwarze Schaf der katarischen Königsfamilie. Und man munkelt, dass er nicht nur dem FC Malaga Geld schuldet, sondern auch wegen anderen Geschäften in Katar viel Geld schuldet. Und daher eine Übernahme durch Al-Kalaifi bzw. über Katar Sports Investment, die Firma, die ihr dahinter steckt, dass dort eine Einigung schnell erzielt werden könnte. Weil, wie gesagt, Al-Tani da ja überall in der Kreide steht. Und das könnte die Situation beim FC Malaga etwas de-blockieren. Denn im Moment ist es tatsächlich so, dass dem Verein komplett die Hände gebunden sind, was Investitionen oder was allgemein die Entwicklung anbelangt. Denn der Scheich, wie gesagt, hat seine Aktienanteile im Moment gepfändet sind. Und auf der gleichen Seite noch ein Gerichtsverfahren schwebt, in dem noch nicht ganz klar ist, ob ihm, dem Scheich, überhaupt 51 Prozent der Aktienanteile gehören oder sogar noch 97 Prozent. Da ist noch eine dritte Firma involviert, die mal mitinvestiert hat. Zwischendrin. Und es ist also großes juristisches Chaos. Aber Nasser al-Khalifi oder Katar Sports Investment könnte der Schlüssel sein, dieses Ding schneller zu lösen, als es die juristischen Mühlen hinbekommen würden.
Okay.
Hat man jetzt nicht ganz verstanden, oder?
Naja, wir haben ja hier schon über Malaga gesprochen. Und wir wissen ja auch, dass du der Malaga-Experte bist, weil du ja auch dort beheimatet bist und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen komplett neu kamen jetzt manche Sachen nicht für mich. Und dennoch würde ich es jetzt ganz gerne noch mal zusammenfassen und du widersprichst einfach, wenn was falsch ist. Also Malaga ist ja schon länger ein Verein, der quasi Investoren geführt ist, beziehungsweise wo der Präsident eine Mehrheit hält. Ob das jetzt 51 Prozent oder 97 Prozent ist dann ja für die Gerichte noch relevant. Aber er hatte auf jeden Fall das Sagen. Malaga, sportlich lief es da nicht gut. Jetzt ist es so, dass Altani nicht mehr sein Präsidentenamt ausüben durfte. Wie habe ich mir das vorzustellen, wenn dann ein Gericht darüber fändet? Also mussten dann einfach die sportlichen Verantwortlichen sich nicht mehr mit dem Präsidenten abstimmen? Gab es dann Richter oder Richterin, die gesagt haben, okay cool, ich mache das jetzt? Also das habe ich nur nicht so ganz verstanden.
Genau, so ist es eigentlich, Max. Also du hast es schon ganz gut angerissen, Althani hatte gar kein Sagen mehr und hatte auch keine Mitarbeiter mehr im Verein, die ihm irgendwie zuarbeiten oder Informationen stecken konnten. Das war komplett weg. Es gab eine Richterin in dem Fall, die einen Geschäftsführer eingesetzt hat und die sind im stetigen Austausch, was Entscheidungen anbelangt. Dieser Geschäftsführer muss alle Entscheidungen sich von der Richterin absegnen lassen. Und finanziell hat er einen richtig guten Job gemacht. Der FC Malaga war tief verschuldet. Also übernommen hat, 2020 steht jetzt finanziell sehr gut da. Aber man hat natürlich auch gemerkt, dass sportliche Kompetenz jetzt nicht mehr da ist. Und dementsprechend ging es steil bergab. Also, ich meine, es ging ja schon seit eigentlich diesem Viertelfinale der Champions League gegen Dortmund. Dieses berühmte 2013 ging es eigentlich nur bergab für den FC Malaga. Zuerst in der ersten Liga ging es die Plätze runter, dann in der zweiten Liga. Und jetzt stehen wir tatsächlich kurz vor dem Schritt in die dritte Liga. Zehn Punkte Rückstand auf das rettende Ufer bei noch zwölf verbleibenden Saisonspielen. Das wird eine ganz, ganz harte Nummer. Außer vielleicht einer aus Katar lässt ein paar Geldkoffer rüberwandern zu irgendwelchen Schiedsrichtern oder Verbänden. Das ist in Spanien ja auch gern gesehen, sage ich jetzt mal vorsichtig.
Aber ich vermute, ich hoffe zumindest nicht, wenn die Richterin die Geldkoffer freigeben muss.
Das wahrscheinlich nicht, aber da schalten sich dann wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwelche Mittelsmänner ein. Aber es ist wirklich sehr, sehr dubios, was passiert ist. Du hast es richtig angesprochen, ich reise nochmal kurz ab. 2010 hat Althani den Verein erworben, damals 97 Prozent der Anteile. Er hat es innerhalb von drei Jahren mit Wahnsinnsinvestitionen geschafft, ins Viertelfinale der Champions League zu kommen mit unglaublichen Spielern. Er hat dann aufgrund dieser Niederlage sich bedrohen gefühlt, unter anderem von der FIFA hat dann seine Freude am Verein verloren, hat dann eigentlich nur noch Geld aus dem Verein rausgezogen, vor allen Dingen auch für private Zwecke. Und so ging es sportlich bergab, 2020 wurde dann auch gerichtlich abgesetzt. Und jetzt stehen wir da, als drittletzter Verein in der zweiten Liga. Und so bitter, wie es klingt eigentlich, zumindest aus meiner Sicht, ist die einzigste Lösung tatsächlich jetzt, eine schnelle Lösung zumindest, dass Nasser Al-Khalifi vom PSG oder die Kata-Investmentsports-Gruppe den Verein kauft und damit diese prekäre Situation entblockieren würde. Ansonsten gibt es einen Schritt in die dritte Liga und wir müssten warten, bis das Gericht irgendwann entscheidet, wer, was wem gehört, um dann den Weg frei zu machen vielleicht für neue Investoren.
Also mit Investoren, die Premier League einholen, ist ja so ein beliebter Thread von Khaled Nahar auf Twitter. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Das ist jetzt ein, zwei, mehrere Beispielen, dass man da sehr gut einreihen könnte. Aber trotzdem habe ich eine Sache jetzt noch nicht ganz verstanden. Also ich kann quasi nachvollziehen, dass es eine Nähe gibt zwischen Katar und dem FC Malaga und dass es ja dann auch easy money wäre, sage ich jetzt mal. Also du kriegst wahrscheinlich für wenig Investment, kriegst du dann eben halt auch einen Verein, der ja auch eine gewisse Tradition hat. Aber du kriegst ja eben auch einen Verein, bei dem ja jetzt einfach seit zehn Jahren sportlich eigentlich wenig bis gar nichts funktioniert, der mit ziemlicher Sicherheit in die dritte spanische Liga absteigt. Was könnte denn ein strategisches Interesse von Katar da überhaupt dahinter stecken, sich den FC Malaga zu sichern?
Ja, man hat natürlich ein wahnsinnig großes Potenzial hier, ein tolles Umfeld. Man hat ein tolles Stadion, man hat eine große Stadt, man hat hier an der Costa del Sol natürlich nicht nur einen Fußballklub der FC Malaga heißt, sondern in Marbella und in anderen Küstenregionen sehr viel internationales, zahlungskräftiges Publikum. Hier gehen die Scheiße quasi ein und aus auch im Sommer. Also die haben hier alle irgendwo ihre Hütten stehen. Also das ist geschäftlich schon ganz interessant. Und was Paris, glaube ich, anstrebt, beziehungsweise die Katar Investment Group, kann Alexis ja vielleicht auch noch was dazu sagen, ist sich auf verschiedenen Ligen, europäischen Ligen, breit zu machen. Ich glaube auch, über 20 Prozent der Aktienanteile von Sporting Braga in Portugal gehört zu dieser Gruppe. Man ist ja, glaube ich, auch an West Ham dran. Men United hast du vorher schon angesprochen. Man sucht sich in Spanien noch einen Club. Also man hat ja schon so ein bisschen die Ansicht, dass sich dieses Quartal Investment Sports oder überhaupt Quartal in der Hinsicht ausbreiten möchte in den verschiedenen Ligen. In Deutschland geht das ja nicht, aber in Spanien geht das, in Portugal geht das, in England geht das. Und da ist so ein bisschen die Strategie, glaube ich, die große, die da in dem Fall dahinter steckt.
Multi-Club-Ownership, also einem Unternehmen, einem Investor. Mehrere Vereine gehören in mehreren Ligen. Das wird wahrscheinlich das nächste große Thema im europäischen Fußball. Du hast gesagt, das geht in der Bundesliga nicht. Ja, außer man ist herter BSC. Und dann kommt Triple Seven. Und man muss sich aus wirtschaftlicher Notgedrungenheit komplett diesem Investor ausliefern. Und gehört dann eben auch zu so einem Multi-Club-Ownership-Konstrukt. Das wird wahrscheinlich wirklich ein riesiges Thema werden. Ob es irgendwie den Verbänden gelingt und den Ligen dagegen sich zu schützen. Weil das kann ja eigentlich auch nicht der Sinn sein, dass eben dann ein Investor sich einfach sechs verschiedene Teams in sechs verschiedenen Ligen kauft und dann so harte Transferverhandlungen stattfinden wie bei Leipzig und Salzburg. Auch wenn handelnde Akteure vorgeben, dass ja angeblich da gar keine Spieler mehr gewechselt werden und das getrennte Vereine werden seitdem beide in der Champions-League gespielt hätten. Das ist alles Quatsch. Und das ist eine... Na gut, aber ich möchte mich jetzt nicht eschofieren.
Der CFC Genua ist im Übrigen in der Saison abgestiegen, als Tribal 7 eingestiegen ist.
Aber gut. Aber dann habe ich das jetzt verstanden. Danke dir, Fabian. Und wir werden einfach genauer Augen drauf haben, denn man muss auf solche Themen inzwischen ein Auge drauf haben, wenn man Sportjournalist ist. Wäre ja irgendwie... Ist interessant, wir haben jetzt viel über Malaga gesprochen und kein einziges Mal über die sportliche Situation, außer, dass es schlecht läuft. Aber gut, das ist halt... So ist moderner Fußball, so ist vielleicht auch moderner Sportjournalismus. Und dadurch, dass ich dich hier in der Rotation drin habe, weiß ich, naja, das können wir jederzeit später nachholen. Wir haben aber noch so viele andere Themen, dass wir jetzt weiter springen müssen, weil wir nämlich auch nicht ganz so einfache Themen zum Teil noch haben. Mario, ich würde ganz gerne mit dir noch sprechen über etwas, was jetzt eben am gestrigen Abend und am gestrigen Tag passiert ist. Nämlich, es hat jetzt das Rückspiel zwischen Napoli und Eintracht Frankfurt stattgefunden. Und irgendwie würde es sich, glaube ich, auch falsch anfühlen, wenn wir über die internationalen Ligen sprechen und auch vorhin ja auch schon das erfolgreiche Abschneiden der italienischen Vereine in der Champions League angesprochen haben. Aber eben nicht auch mit Abbilden. Dass es ja auch diesen Fanausschluss gab, dieses unwürdige Hin und Her mit italienischen Depeschen und Dekreten und Frankfurter Antworten darauf, einer zum Teil ganz räudigen journalistischen Begleitung, wo die übelsten Klischees über Fußballfans zitiert wurden und als Grundlage dafür genommen wurden, diese Grundrechtseingriffe zu rechtfertigen. Auf der anderen Seite aber natürlich auch, das soll man nicht vergessen, wir haben jetzt auch Gewalt gesehen rund um dieses Spiel gestern, was ja sportlich völlig eindeutig war. 3 zu 0 Napoli, im Grunde mit dem 1 zu 0 war dieses Spiel vorbei. Wie blickst du denn jetzt, auch wenn es jetzt immer noch quasi mittendrin ist eigentlich, wie blickst du denn auf alles, was wir da jetzt erlebt haben?
Mir ist ja sehr angenervt, ehrlicherweise, weil werden wir uns mal darüber im Klaren, was das auch für die Eintracht für ein Spiel gewesen wäre, für viele Leute, die ich kenne, die es mit der Eintracht halten. Wir haben uns irgendwie bei der Auslosung drauf gefreut, dass das im Stadio Vigo Maradona ein Wahnsinns-Ritt wird mit toller Stimmung. Das hat das alles irgendwie schon richtig vermisst in den letzten Tagen, Wochen. Das ganze Thema ist natürlich zum einen skandalös, dass das so umgesetzt wird von den Behörden. Zum anderen finde ich, du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, mega daneben will ich auch gar nicht weiter groß darauf eingehen, ob sich da irgendwelche Redakteure selber einen Namen machen wollen und einen Shitstorm provozieren, weil sie irgendeinen Dünnpfiff schreiben und da alle Klischees bedienen. Und trotzdem hast du die Uhr danach stellen können, dass dann auch was passiert. Ich bin der Meinung, dass die Ausgangslage mit dem Fanausschluss vielleicht sogar noch schlimmer werden lassen hat, was jetzt gestern und auch heute noch passiert ist. Ich glaube, heute haben auch noch mal Napoli-Fans probiert, an das Hotel ranzukommen, wo noch Überbleibsel der Frankfurter Fans-Szene waren. Und ja, das ist insgesamt – ich warte jetzt nur darauf, dass sich jetzt welche hinstellen und sagen, haben wir es doch gesagt, deswegen keine Auswärtsfans. Ich glaube, wenn da ein Großteil, also wenn da normal die Fans angereist wären, klar ist da nicht auszuschließen, dass auch was passiert. Aber wenn dann auch Fans da gewesen wären, mit der Absicht ins Stadion zu gehen und sich nicht einfach in der Stadt ihre toxische Männlichkeit auszuleben, dann wäre das eventuell anders ausgesehen. Denn das muss man ja klar sagen, und da haben viele Leute auch ihren Punkt. In bestimmten Fanszenen, auch in Italien immer noch, ist das ein geliebtes Bild von bestimmten Subkulturen, Ultras, Hooligans eben eins, was sich über körperliche Gewalt definiert. Und da muss ich dann auch sagen, kann ich es verstehen, nicht, dass ich das gut finde bzw. nachvollziehen kann, aber ich kann verstehen, warum das passiert ist, dass wenn dann Frankfurt-Fans gemeinsam mit Atalanta-Fans, wo eine Freundschaft besteht, sich in der Stadt breit machen und sich da einmal Hallo sagen, habe ich jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, dass sich italienische Ultras sagen, ja gut, dann kommt hier unsere Stadt, gehört euch, macht ihr mal. Also, dass das dann gestern so eskaliert, finde ich, war fast vorauszusehen und da weiß man aber tatsächlich, dadurch, dass ich selber nicht vor Ort war, kann ich natürlich auch schwer einschätzen, was zu welchem Zeitpunkt losging. Klar ist, dass erst 300 Frankfurter am Tag davor da waren, dann insgesamt waren es, nachdem noch welche nachgereist waren, insgesamt glaube ich 600, die auch von der Polizei beim Begleitet wurden. Dann habe ich aber auch Videos gesehen, wo das so eine Art Katz-und-Maus-Spiel ist, also wo man dann auch sagen muss, dass da dann schon auch das Gebaren der Auswärtsfans, finde ich, schon so wahrgenommen wird, als wäre man dann jetzt nicht nur zum Espresso trinken, auch die Plaza gegangen. Dann haben sich da die Napoli-Ultras gezeigt, die versucht haben, da zu den Frankfurtern durchzukommen. Es ist viel Feuer gewesen. Aber wie gesagt, ich habe gerade schon erwähnt, dass dann auch versucht wurde, vor allem nach dem Spiel und heute auch noch mal an das Hotel der Frankfurt-Fans ranzukommen. Ich stand jetzt ungefähr vor einer Stunde in den letzten Artikel gelesen in der KZ. Da gab es sieben Festnahmen auf Napolis Seite. Und ja, ungut das alles, wie ich finde. Und dann kommt noch dazu, was ich auch dann habe ich von vielen deutschen Journalisten gelesen, dass die Stimmung im Stadion so enttäuschend war. Kommt noch auf der anderen Seite dazu, dass bei den Napoli Ultras gerade auch eine Art Stimmungsboykott ist, weil das ein Stadion ist, wo die vom Präsidenten, aber auch von der Stadt die Reglementierung sehr streng ist, was angeht, was Trommeln angeht, Fahnen etc. Deswegen, ja, war das alles dann, finde ich, stimmungstechnisch und fantechnisch und das, was ja auch Fußball so besonders macht drum herum, gestern nicht so toll, wie es hätte sein können.
Und wie würdest du das einordnen? Wir haben ganz lange gar nichts von der UEFA gehört und dann hat Schäferin dem ZDF ein Interview gegeben und da hat er gesagt, ja, wir schließen uns der Klage von Eintracht Frankfurt an und es geht nicht, dass Fans ausgeschlossen werden. Und auch da bin ich so hin und her gerissen, denn ich vermute, dass wir vier uns darin einig sind, dass wir nicht wollen, dass grundsätzlich Auswärtsfans nicht mitfahren dürfen und dass wir es wahrscheinlich auch eher kritisch sehen, dass man mit so pauschalen Kollektivstrafen auf die Minderheit, die ein Problem ist, reagiert. Gleichzeitig habe ich auch das Problem oder habe ich zumindest so den Eindruck, die Cheferin macht jetzt das, was für ihn am einfachsten ist, nämlich dass er sagt, ja, ja, also wir hängen uns dann die SGE dran und das geht natürlich überhaupt gar nicht. Aber er wäre ja der Einzige, der mit wiederum Sanktionen gegenüber den italienischen Vereinen und die Vereine, das täte mir jetzt auch Leid, auch für die Fans und so weiter. Aber er könnte ja ganz schnell was machen. Wenn er jetzt sagt, ja, sorry, wenn ihr für die Sicherheit nicht gewährleisten könnt, was ja die Grundlage war, dafür Fans den Zugang zur Stadt zu verbieten, ja, dann dürft ihr halt eben auch keine eigenen Fans oder ein Spiel auf neutralem Boden. Also Cheferin könnte ja eigentlich ganz viele Dinge machen. Stattdessen setzt er sich jetzt hin und sagt, ne, ne, ich bin voll auf Seite der Eintracht. Aber ja, ich weiß nicht, also ich glaube, ich habe meine Ambivalenz jetzt schon zur Sprache gebracht.
Ja, also ich dachte auch, ich habe das Interview gesehen und meinte, ja, aber Kollege, hast du erst bei der Interviewanfrage erfahren, was passiert ist? Also das ist so, er hat sich das sehr leicht gemacht und wirkt auch so, als wäre das ein Vorausgriff, auf was eventuell noch alles kommen kann. Aber dann muss man ihn eben auch klar an die jetzt gesagten Worten dann daran dann nehmen. Denn wenn er das jetzt so sagt und hofft, er wächst genug Gras über die Sache bis zum nächsten Präzedenzfall, dann wäre das auch nicht verwunderlich, weil das machen Sportpolitiker eh ganz gerne. Aber jetzt hat er sich ja klar zumindest zu einer Aussage hinreißen lassen, an der man ihn messen kann.
Ja, andererseits dauern halt diese Verfahren immer so lange. Also es wird ja wieder juristisch, es wird ja wieder so sein, dass ein Gericht irgendwann sagen wird, ja das war juristisch nicht haltbar, weil man darf das halt nicht machen. Es gibt halt Menschenrechte zu denen gehört auch eben, dass man sich frei bewegen kann und so läuft es ja immer, aber das passiert halt in ein paar Jahren und dann interessiert es niemanden mehr oder es ist nicht mehr so wichtig. Und gleichzeitig gibt es ja auch scheinbare Gegenargumente. Also wir haben ja Gewalt im Fußball, wir haben ja auch Fans, die wirklich Hooligans sind und Hooligans sind nicht gleich Ultras, aber es gibt quasi eine Schnittmenge zwischen den beiden, auch wenn die sich vielleicht sogar intern voneinander abgrenzen. Das ist von außen dann auch wirklich schwer zu bewerten. Da verstehe ich dann auch, dass das auch manche Beobachterinnen und Beobachter nicht mehr hinbekommen. Fabian, Alexis, ich würde euch da ganz gerne mit reinholen, weil es gibt es ja in jeder Liga, dass es ein Problem mit Gewalt unter Fans gibt und irgendwie jedes Land versucht, was dagegen zu tun. Aber anscheinend geht keiner den Weg, nicht mal mehr jetzt der deutsche Fußball, den wir hier lange hatten, nämlich dass man eben über letztlich Sozialarbeit in Fan-Abteilungen, in dieser Arbeit quasi versucht, dem entgegenzuwirken, sondern es scheint irgendwie so einen Hang zu Repression zu geben, würde ich jetzt fast schon sagen. Ich weiß nicht. Fabian, wie guckst du auf sowas?
Ja, ganz schwierige Frage natürlich. In Spanien haben wir jetzt zurzeit vielleicht weniger Gewaltgeschichten in den letzten Monaten und Jahren gehabt, aber dafür wieder extreme rassistische Vorkommnisse, die sehr, sehr unschön sind und die natürlich auch hauptsächlich von den Ultrecken kommen. Es ist natürlich keine Entwicklung im Sport. Vielleicht ist es genau das, in der Hinsicht findet überhaupt keine Entwicklung statt und man bekommt das eigentlich überhaupt nicht in den Griff. Es ist schwierig für die Vereine nach wie vor, das irgendwie in den Griff zu bekommen. Wie gesagt, in Spanien haben wir zumindest die großen Schlägereien und diese Zusammentreffen, um sich gegenseitig auf die Fresse zu hauen. Das haben wir Gott sei Dank in den letzten Monaten und Jahren weniger gehabt. Es gab ja vor ein paar Jahren mal sogar einen Todesfall bei einem Spiel von Atletico Madrid. Ich kann mich leider nicht mehr genau in den anderen Vereinen erinnern, aber da haben sich auch ein paar Fan-Gruppen dann zu prügeln getroffen. Da ist einer gestorben. Das ist aber jetzt auch schon fünf, sechs Jahre her.
Aber gibt es das noch oder ist das einfach nur weniger sichtbar? In Deutschland ist es ja zum Beispiel so, dass es das halt noch gibt, aber halt in der Regel nicht mehr in den Innenstädten, sondern auf irgendeinem berühmten Acker und im Wald und Wiesengrund.
Das kann ich dir ganz ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen. Wenn, dann berichten die Medien nicht drüber. Vielleicht gibt es das noch. Aber da ist in den letzten Monaten und Jahren echt sehr, sehr ruhig geworden. Wie gesagt, das Schlimme ist nach wie vor der Rassismus hier. Der ist wirklich taff und das kriegst du auch nicht in die Köpfe der Leute rein. Das halte ich für eine ganz, ganz schwierige Geschichte.
Alexi, wie blickst du da drauf?
In Frankreich haben wir schon das Problem mit den Gegnerfans schon länger. Zum Beispiel beim Klassik. Una Big Masse, Paris Saint-Germain, sie haben seit 2013 keine gegnerischen Fans mehr erlaubt. Das ist fast bei jedem zweiten Spiel, dass keine Gegnerfans vor Ort sind. Bei denjenigen, die erlaubt sind, sind die Mannschaften, die so 200-300 Zuschauer mitbringen. Oder 2-3 Stück wie Monaco. Das Problem ist auch ein gesellschaftliches seit vielen Jahren in Frankreich. Das hat man auch als Gefühl, wie mit dem Rassismus in Spanien von Fabian erklärt oder beschrieben, dass wir kein Ende sehen, dass sowohl die Verantwortlichen von den Vereinen, als auch die politischen Verantwortlichen keine Maßnahmen ergreifen und sich dafür nicht wirklich interessieren. Das ist schon besorgnisierend, aber gleichzeitig schade, weil eine Masse der PSG-Mitfans von beiden Teams ist einfach etwas Wunderbares. Aber ich bin nicht wirklich überrascht, was gerade in Neapel passiert ist gegen die Eintracht. Man weiß noch in der Gruppenphase, was zwischen den Eintracht und den Olympique Marseille los war zwischen den Fans, sei es in Frankfurt oder in Marseille mit Auseinandersetzungen. Man weiß ja auch schon, dass es ein kleiner, aber doch nicht so kleiner Teil der Frankfurter Fans sind, die auch gewalttätig sind. Das ist bei Borussia Dortmund auch so. Es kommen jetzt immer mehr Geschichten über die Dortmunder Fans, die gewalttätig sind, die antisemitismische rufen. Sie haben es jetzt beim Revier-Durby rausgelassen. Es ist schon immer wieder ein Problem und man sieht einfach keine Lösung darin. Dass jetzt, meine Herren, vor wenigen Minuten Jan Infantino wieder gewählt wurde als Vifapräsidenten, ist auch dementsprechend nicht unbedingt eine gute Nachricht.
Ich finde, was die ganze Bewertung extrem schwierig macht, auch noch, Alexi hat es gerade gesagt, du hast es vorhin auch angedeutet, Max, zum einen sind die Szenen an sich ja sehr divers und welche grenzen sich ab und welche nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite ist ja auch sowohl, also vor allem gerade bei der Ultra-Bewegung, finde ich, dass so eine heterogene Subkultur auch, was die Unterschiede zwischen Vereinen angeht, also da wird das teilweise gelebt wie in den 80er, 90ern und bei anderen ist es völlig progressiv und es kommt fast gar nicht zu irgendwelchen Auseinandersetzungen.
Ja, und gleichzeitig eben der Fakt, auf den ja auch Alexis richtigerweise hingewiesen hat, es sind ja gesellschaftliche Entwicklungen, die sich im Fußball nur widerspiegeln und da wird der Fußball auch quasi nicht die Gesellschaft verändern können. Was mich ehrlicherweise frustriert ist, dass es anscheinend offenbar nur über Repression geht und letztlich über Kräfte messen. Das ist dann auch so eine nicht nur verbale Aufrüstung, die auf beiden Seiten passiert. Also auch normale Fans werden begrüßt von Bundespolizisten in Schlagmontur hier in Deutschland und in anderen Ländern. Da kriege ich es natürlich vor allem bei internationalen Spielen mit. Ich meine, ich habe es selbst in Rom erlebt. Da war ich mit der Eintracht im Stadion. Ich kenne sehr viele Berichte von den BVB-Fans damals, als sie in Sevilla waren. Also es gibt ja auch quasi schon so eine Erwartungshaltung. Ja, also wenn du da hingehst, dann musst du auch damit rechnen, das könnte richtig übel werden. Und daraus schließe ich jetzt, dass es auch in anderen Ländern eben vor allem darüber funktioniert, über Verbote und über ja, letztlich, wer von denen ist der Stärkere. Und dann kommt eben dann die Staatsmacht. Und das ist halt das, was mich so frustriert, weil das wird ja zu nichts führen. Also das wird nur dazu führen, dass es immer mal wieder eskaliert, dass es immer mal wieder der eine, die eine Seite der anderen ein Schnippchen schlägt. Also mal werden irgendwie die, die Polizei wird irgendwann, wird mal Fans einkesseln oder irgendwelche Kölner Fans zur Umkehr bewegen und wird das dann als Erfolg verkaufen können. Genauso werden aber halt auch Dortmund- und Essen-Fans, Schalke-Fans überfallen und da Leute kranken raus, Hausreif schlagen und sich dafür feiern. Und in seinem ganzen Destruktivismus macht mich das einfach müde. Und gleichzeitig sehe ich eben das einzige, was dagegen wirken könnte. Vielleicht wäre eben, dass man einfach investiert in die Jugend und in die Begleitung der Jugend. Und um eben zu verhindern, dass Menschen zu solchen Menschen werden, die eben dann über Gewalt sich einen Kick holen oder Probleme lösen wollen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gucke ich eben, was passiert denn da auch im Fußball. Also es ist generell ein gesellschaftliches Ding, aber auch im Fußball. Ja, die Fan-Projekte machen reihenweise zu. Ihnen wird Geld entzogen. Die sagen schon seit ganz vielen Jahren, dass sie eigentlich zu wenig Geld haben. Und da tut sich nichts. Und das ist das, wo ich mich dann auch manchmal frage, warum der Journalismus, jetzt so ganz allgemein gesprochen, so selten bei diesen Themen rauskommt, wenn wir über Gewalt im Fußball sprechen. Sondern ich habe das Gefühl, es hört immer bei der Pyro-Fackel auf, dass ich da drüber aufgeregt würde. Und da kann man sich ja drüber aufregen. Es ist ja auch verboten. Aber warum kommen wir denn nicht zu dem, ja, was könnte man denn konstruktiv machen? Und ich habe das Gefühl, genau dasselbe passiert hier gerade bei der Napoli-Eintracht-Frankfurt-Sache auch, die ja auch nur ein Beispiel von leider vielen ist.
Ja, volle Zustimmung. Und die Fanprojekte finde ich auch ganz wichtiges Thema. In vielen Städten ist ja dann fast eher eigentlich der Freundeskreis, die Ultrakopierungen, die die Arbeit von Street-Workern oder Fanprojekten übernimmt und vielleicht auch Auffangbecken ist für ziellose Heranwachsende, die auf der Suche nach irgendetwas sind.
Das ist ja auch das. Also die Missachtung der Jugend, die Ausbeutung der Jugend und dann gleichzeitig, seid doch einfach mal wieder, habt doch einfach mal wieder Bock auf Arbeit, hatten wir doch früher auch und so. Also ja, es greifen so viele Themen ineinander. Wir müssen irgendwie die Kurve kriegen. Wir sind auch zeitlich schon ein bisschen drüber, wenn einer von euch irgendwie terminische Probleme bekommt, sagt es an. Wir machen jetzt, wenn wir eh schon bei den Scheißthemen sind, ich sage es einfach wie es ist, dann können wir jetzt über Korruption noch sprechen und dann danach wird uns aber Alexi mit einem Sexskandal richtig juicy dann noch hier rausschmeißen aus dieser Ligatur. Oh Gott, was habe ich da gerade gesagt? Ich moderiere einfach weiter, dann versende ich. Fabian, wir müssen noch über Bata sprechen.
Mir fällt gerade auf, es tut mir sehr leid, aber das werde ich mir auf jeden Fall, das ist gut angeteasert, ich werde es mir auf jeden Fall im Nachgang anhören. Leider kann ich jetzt nicht mitdiskutieren, aber ich sehe gerade, dass ich jetzt auch in einer Minute in einen Termin rein muss. Ich würde mich an der Stelle schon mal verabschieden.
Mach das, Mario. Dann bin ich froh, dass ich das schwere Thema noch rechtzeitig angesprochen habe. Mario, danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Der Ed Remedem auf Twitter. Danke dir, Mario. Viel Spaß in deinem anderen Termin.
Ob das Spaß für dich war?
So, und das wird hier so langsam wie bei der Sinfonie, wo einer nach dem anderen der Instrumentalisten rausgeht. Damals wollte damals der Kompositeur gegen seinen Lehnsherr oder seinen Mezzän dafür demonstrieren, dass man doch mal mehr Geld bekommen sollte. So wird jetzt diese Ligatour. Also Barca. Wir haben mitbekommen, dass man an den stellvertretenden Leiter der Spanischen Schiedsrichterkommission über mehrere Jahre hinweg 7 Millionen Euro gezahlt hat. Für Schiedsrichter nahe Leistungen, sagt Barca, also der hätte so Profile erstellt und Schulungen durchgeführt. So genau kann man aber nicht nachweisen. Was hat er denn eigentlich da so ganz konkret gemacht? Und der Verdacht liegt natürlich nahe, warum zahlt man so viel Geld, dass eben hier Korruption vorliegt bzw. eine Beeinflussung zumindest. Und da gab es jetzt neuere Entwicklungen, Fabian.
Ja, so viel Geld über so viele Jahre. Und das kam jetzt tatsächlich nicht nur den Spaniern spanisch vor, sondern auch dem Gericht und der spanischen Staatsanwaltschaft, die eine offizielle Anklage gegen den FC Barcelona eingeleitet hat. Und die wurde jetzt auch gestern stattgegeben. Das heißt, der Fall FC Barcelona beziehungsweise der Fall über die schiedsichtlichen Zahlungen oder die Zahlungen an diesem Schiedsichterausschuss, das wird jetzt vor Gericht ausgeführt, das ganze Thema. Da werden die verschiedenen Parteien vorgeladen und es kommt also hier zu einem richtig großen Gerichtsfall. Und da können wir wirklich sehr gespannt darauf sein, wie das ausgehen wird. Denn in Spanien, und das wissen wir glaube ich ja alle inzwischen, werden diese zwei großen Teams, Real Madrid und FC Barcelona, normalerweise behüte und beschützt wie der eigene Augapfel. Und es ist tatsächlich jetzt ein sehr interessanter Schritt, wie ich finde, dass es jetzt wirklich zur Gerichtsverhandlung kommt. Denn es könnte wirklich derbe Konsequenzen natürlich dann gegen den FC Barcelona geben. Ich denke da auch an die Geschichte, die bei Juve passiert ist in Italien und so weiter. Wir werden sehen, ob es soweit kommt. Aber Fakt ist natürlich, wenn man dem Schiedsrichterausschuss oder dem Vizepräsidenten des Spanischen Verbandes, des Schiedsrichterausschusses über 17 Jahre dann 7 Millionen Euro zusteckt, dann hat das einen faden Beigeschmack. Ich bin sehr gespannt, muss ich tatsächlich sagen, was dabei rauskommt und vor allen Dingen, ob dann wirklich auch eine dementsprechende Verurteilung stattfinden wird.
Und hat sich real dazu inzwischen eigentlich positioniert, weil das hatte ich in der letzten Ligatur angesprochen, der wir das Thema hatten, dass die auffallend ruhig waren und eigentlich sogar eher kritisch, wobei es halt auch ein bisschen schwierig voneinander zu trennen ist. Geht es hier um die Sache und geht es vielleicht um eine ganz, ganz mögliche, also es ist jetzt nur eine Vermutung oder eine These. Es könnte ja auch eine Mitbeteiligung gegeben haben, auch auf Seiten von Real. Also weil häufig war es bisher so, dass Dinge, die Barca gemacht hat, auch Real gemacht hat, ohne dass ich da irgendetwas wüsste, also mit aller Vorsicht gesprochen. Oder ob es einfach nur daran liegt, dass Real im Clinch liegt mit dem Spanischen Verband und das jetzt schon seit Jahren und eigentlich in die Super League will und so weiter und so fort. Oder auch männliche Egos aufeinander prallen.
Also Real Madrid hat zumindest jetzt dieser gemeinsamen Klage auch zugestimmt und ist da quasi mit anderen Vereinen in die Presche gesprungen, um dieses Gerichtsverfahren einzuleiten. Dementsprechend hat sich Real Madrid da jetzt auch klar positioniert. Du hast aber einen Punkt angesprochen und darüber, glaube ich, sollten wir uns schon auch im Klaren sein, auch Real Madrid – vielleicht nicht in der Art und Weise, wie es der FC Barcelona gemacht hat, aber auch Real Madrid – hat seine Finger überall drinstecken, ob es in der Politik sei, ob es bei den Schiedsrichtern sei. Auch die wissen sich die Gunst der Liga und der Spanischen Verbandes zu sichern. Also, ihr solltet trotzdem das Ganze mit Vorsicht genießen. Die wurden halt im Moment nicht irgendwie dabei erwischt, sage ich jetzt mal vorsichtig. Aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass auch dort Sachen passiert sind, die nicht alle völlig einwandfrei waren. Und dementsprechend tut Real Madrid sich ganz gut, sich da noch zurückzuhalten. Wie gesagt, sie haben jetzt damit zugestimmt, dass dieses Verfahren eingeleitet wird, was auch absolut normal ist. Wie gesagt, das haben alle anderen Vereine eher auch gemacht. Aber sonst halten sie sich noch relativ ruhig und da tun sie auch gut daran, denke ich mal.
Und jetzt ermittelt ja dann, glaube ich, der Richter ist es doch in Spanien, glaube ich, oder die Richterin, je nachdem, der dann die Entwicklung übernimmt. Also Staatsanwaltschaft, Reich, Klage ein und dann ist es ein Ermittlungsrichter. Genau, genau so ist es. Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, wir werden da noch oft genug darüber sprechen, deswegen reicht vielleicht dieses kurze Update, denn ich weiß, alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die warten doch jetzt sowieso auf den Sex-Skandal bei Orangy, beziehungsweise was da überhaupt los ist. Alexis, bring uns auf den Aktorentstand. Wieviel müssen wir über Sportliches reden? Muss ich jetzt überhaupt die Tabelle der Ligue 1 aufmachen und gucken, wie es um Jean Angers gerade so steht? Oder hat es damit gar nichts zu tun?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Man kann schon kurz zusammenfassen, dass Angers vergleichbar ist von der sportlichen Entwicklung, aber auch vom Interesse in Frankreich zu diesem Verein, nämlich gar keine. Mir hätte es gehoffnet, weil Angers jetzt jahrelang der Ligue 1 war. Man hatte den französischen Christian Streich, der lange Stefan Moulin war, der über zehn Jahre dort Cheftrainer war. Seit er weg ist, geht es nur bergunter. In dieser Saison hat Angers jetzt nach 27 Spieltagen 10 Punkte geholt. Der Abstieg ist so gut wie besiegelt. Man sollte im Sommer ohne Trainer und Mannschaft stehen, aber vor allem ohne Präsidenten, denn er wird von Said Schabani, der Präsident von Skodange, angeklagt. Er ist übrigens als besten Vereinspräsidenten der Liga 2019 gewählt. Er ist jetzt von sieben Mitarbeiterinnen angeklagt worden wegen sexueller Belästigung, wenn nicht mehr, und jetzt muss er vor Gericht im Juni. Diese Geschichte kam schon vor eineinhalb Jahren raus und dann, zu dem gleichen Zeitpunkt, wurde ein Spieler auch von einer Frau angezeigt, weil er vor der Haustür, das war seine Nachbarin, hat seine Hose runtergemacht und sein bestes Stück gezeigt zur Nachbarin, die ihn dann sofort angezeigt hat. Das war der Anfang vom Ende für Angers, denn danach kamen immer mehr solche Geschichten. Letzte Geschichte, letzte Woche mit dem Interimstrainer Abdel Boazama, der einen Spieler von ihm schützen wollte, der auch angezeigt wurde wegen sexueller Belästigung oder Vergewaltigung sogar. Boazama hat den unglaublichen Satz rausgebracht, aber wir haben eh alle schon Frauen sexuell angefasst. Das war natürlich fatal für ihn, er musste dann seine Posten sofort abräumen und jetzt steht Angers ohne Trainer da und das sorgt natürlich für ein Skandal nach dem anderen und für ein sehr schlechtes Image eines Vereins, der bisher schuldlos war, wirklich ein absolutes Vorzeigeprofiferein war in den letzten Jahren bis seit 2021, 2022, wo dieser Verein einfach nur noch für negative Schlagzeilen sorgt und jetzt nicht nur extra sportliche Sachen, sondern jetzt auch natürlich sportliche Sachen und man hat das Gefühl, dass dieser Verein wirklich an die Wand gefahren wird und dann durch diese sexuellen Geschichten auch noch wirklich ganz große Probleme haben wird, um sich davon zu erholen, weil man hat schon das Gefühl, dass dieser Verein in der nächsten Saison auch um den Klassenerhalt in der 2. Liga kämpfen muss, weil wer wird dieser Verein übernehmen, mit welchen finanziellen Mitteln und wohl in einem Zeitpunkt, wo man ein nagelneues, renoviertes Stallion bauen lassen hat und wirklich sehr modern ist, mit einem auch großen Kern an Fans. Aber all diese Geschichten sorgen natürlich für Skandale, aber auch für Tristesse oder Inange.
Aber wenn das zum Beispiel sieben Mitarbeiterinnen sind, dann spricht das ja auch dafür, dass über einen längeren Zeitraum passiert ist, diese sexuellen Übergriffe. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja bei weitem nicht das Einzige, was wir jetzt im Männerfußball erlebt haben, wo man solche Beispiele hat. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob jetzt unsere Aufmerksamkeit darauf hingeschafft ist oder ob gerade mehr Dinge als sonst an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, eben was sexuelle Gewalt gegen Frauen angeht. Vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass es inzwischen ein anderes Bewusstsein dafür gibt, Dinge zur Anzeige zu bringen. Glaubst du, Ingenie ist wirklich ein Einzelfall? Das ist natürlich jetzt hochspekulativ und so weiter. Aber man muss jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel hypothetisch sich dazudenken, um halt Muster zu erkennen im Fußball. Dass wir immer wieder Spieler haben, die wegen Dingen beschuldigt und angeklagt werden, dass wir immer wieder Vereine und männliche Funktionäre haben, die diese Spieler dann schützen, die auch sich selbst schützen. Wie blickst du da drauf? Einzelfall oder vielleicht Symptom eines größeren Musters?
Ich befürchte, dass es kein Einzelfall ist, weil warum soll das nur in Angers passieren? Eigentlich hätte ein Verein, den man nie hätte zutrauen können, dass solche Geschichten auf einmal rauskommen. Ich denke schon, dass es bei anderen Vereinen der Fall ist, nur da werden die Hauptschulen wahrscheinlich noch geschützt. Die Frage ist, wie lang. Irgendwann kommt immer alles raus. Ich wäre sehr verwundert, wenn da nicht mehr mehr rauskommt in den nächsten Jahren. Aber auch bei anderen Vereinen, auch mal in Deutschland oder in England, wo auch alles unter dem Teppich versteckt wird. Es kann nicht sein, dass bei Vereinen, wo so viel los ist, so viele Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen, dass es nur ein Einzelfall bleiben kann. Das halte ich für so gut wie ausgeschlossen.
Was ja schon ein unglaublich deprimierender Befund ist eigentlich und dennoch muss man dir da natürlich zustimmen. Löst es denn auch eine größere Debatte aus in Frankreich? Das habe ich natürlich jetzt nicht so im Blick, wie die Medien über sowas berichten.
Nicht unbedingt, weil Angers ist nur Angers. Wie gesagt, wenn jetzt in Hoffenheim auch solche Geschichten passieren würden, wäre natürlich die Titelseite zwei, drei Tage. Aber Hoffenheim ist nicht Dortmund, nicht Frankfurt und noch auch nicht Bayern München. Deswegen kann man froh sein, auch wenn es sich komisch anhört, dass es nur Angers ist, aber stell dir vor, es wäre bei Marseille oder Olympique Lyonnais oder natürlich auch Katar St. Germain der Fall, was es dann für Schlagzeilen bringen würde. Dann wäre das natürlich auch ein großes Thema in den französischen Tagesthemen. Aber es ist nur Angers und hoffentlich bleibt es so, dass nicht andere Vereine kommen, dass alles normal läuft. Aber ich befürchte schon, dass da immer mehr rauskommt durch unsere heutige Welt, dass Angers nicht ein Einzelfall bleiben wird.
Ohje, was für ein deprimierendes Thema und ich möchte mich ausdrücklich dafür entschuldigen, dass ich das so launisch mit Sexskandal anmoderiert habe. Ich hatte gehofft, dass es um irgendwas mit Konsent geht und dass da einfach viele Leute Spaß miteinander hatten, aber das war dann natürlich völlig unpassend. Da habe ich einfach total die falsche Abzweigung genommen, weil ich mich nicht vorher informiert habe, was in Angers so los ist. Also dafür entschuldigung, das war total unpassend und ja, aber gut, das ist mir jetzt so passiert. Es tut mir sehr leid. Muss ich das nächste Mal ein bisschen besser arbeiten. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch, dass ihr euch quasi, dass ihr in die Verlängerung gegangen seid mit dieser Ligatur, die nicht immer einfache Themen hatte, aber so ist das eben halt auch im Fußball. Wir sind quasi das Abbild des Abbilds. Der Fußball ist ein Abbild der Gesellschaft und wir müssen dann dieses Abspiel dann reportieren. Umso mehr danke ich euch beiden, dass ihr hier war. Zum einen Fabian Pakulat, der Ed-Rosen-Gartler, auf Twitter. Danke dir, Fabian, dass du mal wieder hier mit dabei warst und da bin ich sehr gespannt, was du dann über das neue katarische Projekt Malaga in Zukunft so berichten wirst, hier im Rasenfunk. Danke dir. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Alexis Menuge. Danke, dass du auch diese Themen neben dem Platz mitbringst, denn sie sind wichtig. Danke dir, Alexis, dass du wieder im Rasenfunk warst.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, das nächste Mal. Das wird dann in zwei Wochen stattfinden. So ist zumindest der aktuelle Plan. Aber das ist unser aktueller Rhythmus. Nächste Woche werdet ihr im Kurzpass hoffentlich zwei Folgen hören. Einmal zum letzten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltag. Da möchte ich euch schon mal empfehlen. Die letzte Folge, da habe ich Svenja Hut vom VfL Wolfsburg interviewt und wir haben natürlich auch die Spiele analysiert. Im nächsten Frauen-Kurzpass wird dann Nina Lürsen von Werder Bremen interviewt werden. Wenn die euch noch nicht sagt, dann hört euch dieses Interview an. Danach wisst ihr, warum ihr ein Auge auf sie haben sollte. Ganz interessante Sportlerin, die auch eine Meinung hat, dass es sehr wohltuend. Also das wird dann am nächsten Montag erscheinen und am nächsten Donnerstag. So denn die Gästeplanung es zulässt, werden wir hoffentlich über die 2. Männer-Bundesliga Deutschland sprechen. Das ist das, was hier im Kurzpass passiert und in der Schlusskonferenz bekommt ihr natürlich am Wochenende wieder einen Rückblick auf den Männerspieltag der 1. Liga. Also es geht einfach genauso weiter wie die letzten Wochen. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, unterstützt den Rasenfunk bitte finanziell rasenfunk.de support das Club, denn nur diese Unterstützung macht den Rasenfunk möglich und nur das ermöglicht uns auch Unabhängigkeit. Und vielleicht haben wir heute auch so ein paar Themen gehabt, wo man gehört hat, es ist nicht so schlecht unabhängig zu sein. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.